[MUSIC]
How do you decide then whether or not you
have a shot at getting into Stanford?
>> That's a great question, that's
probably the million-dollar question.
And I'm hoping all of what we discuss
today will give applicants insight into
whether or not they have a shot.
But, I think if I had
to go to the essence,
what is absolutely most important
in making that decision,
we're trying to answer two questions
on the admissions committee.
The first is,
is this particular applicant going to be
engaged academically when
they come to our program?
And the second is, what kind of impact
will they have after they graduate?
And if you think, well, we care about
their educational engagement because we're
a higher education institution,
we want our classroom to be vibrant.
You probably know as a student the more
interested folks are when they're learning
and curious the better and
richer that experience will be.
And then on the flip side,
we do care and believe in our tag line.
We want to know when we're
selecting these students that they
have the potential to change lives, change
organizations, and change the world.